[Music]
blasting off on a mission to earth's
orbit
this rocket is carrying a laboratory
module one of two outstanding components
of china's space station
when the final piece is launched later
this year chen gong will be fully
operational
china has made its ambitions clear
it wants to catch up with the u.s and
russia to become a powerhouse in space
technology the figures are really
startling and the americans are still by
far the world leaders in the number of
rockets that they launch but china is
catching up very very quickly they're
now also aiming at a human presence in
space which has two purposes one
scientific but the other of course is
prestige
the project has enormous political
significance
it's been a priority for president xi
jinping he's poured billions of dollars
into china's space program
and the completion of chengong is set to
coincide with another milestone his 10th
year in office
china's goals go well beyond earth's
orbit
a manned moon mission could be on the
cards by the end of the decade i would
have laughed at this as an idea three or
five years ago but now we have to take
everything that china says very
seriously indeed the first building
blocks for the project the mission that
will land the first chinese people on
the moon is already under construction
they've shown us pictures in the factory
of the modules so this is going to
happen
they won't have a base on the moon by
the end of this decade but there is now
a realistic possibility that a chinese
woman or a chinese man could be the next
person to set foot on the moon
china has been excluded from the
international space station since 2011
when the us banned nasa from working
with it
that's only heightened beijing's desire
to establish a station of its own
and as china continues to reach for the
stars there's no telling what else its
space program might achieve in the
decades to come
vinton molyneux al jazeera
[Applause]